huge news today Fox News fired Bill
O'Reilly yeah yeah the head of Fox News
said there's only one place for an angry
old guy that demeans women and that's
the White House Bill O'Reilly has been
fired from Fox News after being accused
of sexually harassing up to twelve women
yeah apparently O'Reilly violated Fox
News is strict eleven woman limit
Elevens fine you go one beyond eleven
that's crazy that's nuts
everyone's wondering where is Bill
O'Reilly Bill O'Reilly is vacationing in
Italy yesterday he was spotted at the
Vatican shaking hands with Pope Francis
yeah man O'Reilly really will hit on
anything in a dress that's all it takes
future of the Mexican border wall is in
doubt now what if you heard about that
a new report just came out it says the
US border wall could cost three times as
much as previously estimated yeah
however Trump says he'll keep costs down
with his secret business trick called
not paying for stuff it works really
well here's your bill screw it a recent
security purge by Facebook has
unintentionally gotten rid of millions
of likes millions of likes are just gone
just think all those wasted hours wasted
ridiculous
here's a crazy story enough you saw this
an archaeologist is claiming he's
discovered an amazing lost city in
Kansas yeah then he realized he just got
drunk and watched The Wizard of Oz it's
a proud amazing crowds like well that
would make sense yeah that would work I
suppose crazy story it's been revealed
that there's a man in Canada who has 27
wives 27 wives he said the hardest part
is waiting for all 27 to go to bed so I
can watch porn come on fellas you know
what I'm talking about and you ladies
know what I'm talking about I think we
all know what I'm talking about
you know what I'm talking I've busted I
busted this guy a lot of time I go to
bed and you stay up and watch porn cuz
we live together according to a new
study speaking of sex according to a new
study frequent sex frequent sex improves
your memory
yeah in a related story where am I and
who are you people
I think you guys know what I'm talking
about
I've been married a long time yeah and I
think you ladies know don't pay Piketty
that got crazy fast that guy whoever I
became that guy has to go away yeah
or stay I'll only be that guy oh no
great that's what you want we've got a
great show I want to be there for the
first meeting at your kids school when
that guy shows up that's my kid do
[Laughter]
you